[Applaus]
ich weiß nicht wie es euch geht aber für
mich ist 2018 jetzt schon gelaufen 2018
wird wieder das jahr der alten so wie
letztes jahr
das jahr davor und überhaupt die letzten
30 jahre
die deutsche gesellschaft ist eine der
fünf ältesten der welt wer in
deutschland 45 jahre alt ist gehört zu
jüngeren hälfte bei bundestagswahlen
kommen auf einen erst wähler drei letzt
wähler schätze ich den jungen gehört
zwar die zukunft aber den alten alles
andere wählerstimmen macht und geld in
deutschland herrscht das alte reich
gerade beim thema
generationengerechtigkeit geht es
natürlich auch um armut
deutschland hat so viel mehr zu bieten
als nur kinderarmut und altersarmut was
ist zum beispiel mit der armut
dazwischen das ist vielfalt wie wird man
arm armut hängt in deutschland vor allem
davon ab wie reicht die eigenen eltern
sind wer sich einfach so in eine ärmere
familie gewähren lässt hat gleich
deutlich weniger chancen
augen auf bei der familien wahl erben
ist der eine weg zum wohlstand in
deutschland der andere wäre ein früheres
geburtsdatum gewesen wenn ich mir mehr
mühe gegeben hätte wäre ich 30 jahre
früher auf die welt gekommen
so oder so ich hätte mich bei der
befruchtung der eizelle mehr anstrengen
müssen
das hätte mein leben besser gemacht
vergleichen wir das mal kurz vor 30
jahren war das studium im schnitt mit 28
vorbei heute mit 24 damals gab es
kündigungsschutz heute kündigungs was
damals hieß es die rente ist sicher
heute heißt es hahahaha
hahahaha man könnte ja sagen wo ist das
problem deutschland ist ein reiches land
alle erben zurück vor zurück vor zurück
aber nur jeder zwanzigste der 30 bis 60
jährigen rechnet überhaupt mit einem
erbe von mehr als 300.000 euro und von
300.000 euro kann man sich in einer
deutschen innenstadt noch nicht mal eine
wohnung leisten
man hat also noch nicht mal was davon
wenn die verwandten draufgehen
das ist die durchschnittliche
lebenserwartung in deutschland im
schnitt wird man in deutschland mit null
jahren geboren darf aber erst 18 jahre
später mitwählen
warum ist das nur auf der einen seite
eingeschränkt ein klarer weiterer fall
von jugend diskriminierung
ich finde man sollte das wahlalter bis
63 begrenzen und die die sich im letzten
bereich beschweren dann kann man ja
sagen seid doch froh dass wir noch lebt
in menschheitsgeschichte schnitt seite
schon längst tot
das ist eine zugabe ich weiß dieses
video wird jetzt bei den alten nicht so
gut ankommen aber das hier ist ja nicht
fürs zdf sondern fürs internet und da
ist die jüngere zielgruppe unterwegs